[Music]
you're on the side of a mob
with the side of the police you can't be
pro-law enforcement and pro-insurrection
you can't be pro-law enforcement of
pro-george floyd you can't be pro-law
enforcement or black lives matter you
can't be pro-law enforcement and pro
looking the other way when your son
fills out in a federal gun form
correctly
but you know whatever you want i guess
is fine
you know is he gonna really run out of
law in order because yeah yeah he's no
he is gonna alienate some people well i
mean looking at that diary he should run
a law and order svu
oh jesus christ
oh [ __ ]
oh man
sorry i don't know you're taking a dab
oh my god that's
it's just that's a wrap right
down show's over folks that might be one
of the funniest flags in the top 10
funniest league voices ever
i'm sure judas goats is gonna clip it
put it on twitter um
thank you judas coats damn that's messed
up munch
[Laughter]
the whole episode is just iced tea going
like i want the peanuts and they're like
it's above your pay grade
why these secret service [ __ ]
walking up in here and bothering us
and then [ __ ] of course munchies in
the back going i'm just gonna read the
diary see if there's any details we
missed hey guys are they making a movie
out of this i'm asking for a friend hey
munch i know you're going to read that
diary but why are you reaching for
lotion
there's no reason you need lotion and
evidence from and then somebody has to
explain because they make that somebody
ask oh well that's like a modern anne
frank starring and someone has to
explain to uh to [ __ ] iced tea what
the holocaust is and who anne frank was
oh man i thought that was just a bunch
of stories
he started talking about the ballpoint
pen
i have french why is this written in
ballpoint pen i've read that it wasn't
invented till the 50s they go through a
whole lab scene where the lat you know
they always have the lab person
explaining how the pen wasn't invented
they go through the whole thing
now mariska hardigay has to like
relieve him of duty because he has
problematic beliefs
hey uh hey what was his name finn in the
show i think sorry yeah detective um
so we saw some of your facebook posts
and munch was really offended he was the
most offended
oh [ __ ] so somebody in the chat ass with
the biden thing so where does ray epps
fall into all of this
you're either on the side of ray epps or
you're on the side of ray epps oh [ __ ]
that's not what i wish
that's a good plate
you are you on the front end or the
background the bad ray upside or your
stand on the side of the good wraps
what happened men have two wolves in
them and they're both ramps
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
gregorimo you see ice ballpoint pens are
just imagining i'm imagining the
forensic person they always have in the
lab coat explaining
you know what i mean listen i need you
to run some fingerprint tests for a case
of mine but i also want you to explain
to me why smoke stacks that aren't
attached to a building can work
and explain to me why you won't put a
bunch of people in a building just to
kill them but then you're gonna have a
maternity ward law and order s v jew
it seems redundant
oh [ __ ]
god damn it
it don't even get me started on them
ferrets wheels and munch is like i'll
look at the videos with the maternity
ward
i got it
it's just it it's just him
like trying to ask munch all these
questions but not in a malicious way
right right he's not just genuinely like
no you're my friend i want you to
explain it to me why they got wooden
doors
explaining the wooden doors
and munch is trying to be patient
because they've been partners for like
20 years and it's like look you've just
been hearing a lot of this information
on the internet not understand but like
i've seen the pictures explain the doors
yeah but you know what the problem is
merc she's saying all this while they're
eating lunch at a jewish deli loudly and
much it's just
much like hey can you lower your voice
within please just a little bit
i'm just asking questions what happened
in this country you can't ask a question
black man can't ask a question
then he goes on charlemagne's show
yo dog i've had some questions for a
long time too trust me but i can't say
nothing i'm saying because we got like
the number one morning show
in new york oh god yeah charlotte
manhattan used to have some problematic
behavior as they would call he does i
still like him i know i know i know but
like he's a white hating black guy but i
still love him like there's people i
love people that'll be like i can't like
that guy because he's black and he hates
white people i'm like you're white and
hate black people who cares remember
when he remember when he [ __ ] called
out kamala for hanging up on him like
that's what i liked him i know he's a
lefty what i get a black power guy or
whatever but but when when kamala we
asked her a hard question and i thought
they might have been locking up black
people or whatever she just like hung up
and he was like yeah she left she don't
want to answer the question she's
pretending she doesn't hear me
sorry you can't be a party of law and
order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots i don't
call them patriots i call them heroes